jennifer est ce que vous avez démarré à
la star academy oui mais j'ai fait une
émission avant la première émission ces
graines de stars mademoiselle jenifer
bartoli
[Applaudissements]
c'est maya
duclos
lui mais tu là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore comédienne et marne parce que
pour moi c'est juste une des plus belles
filles de francs mais deux aides aux
français trouvent toujours chez m
c'est vrai adoptez les chocs et mandy
regarde moi j'ai les yeux tournés vers
moi j'ai pas encore par mois qui suit la
pente
c'est très sympa non mais j'ai quitté la
référence au niveau mais il a donné à
tout le monde que truman il est en même
temps c'est ça ton charme c'est que tu
le sais pas trop je vais les faire vous
l'avez fait fort boyard ou pas non vous
avez envie de le faire non vous aviez
chanter je te promet également avec
venise en 2003 vous avez partagé la
scène avec avec johnny c'est un moment
qui restera gravé dans votre mémoire à
toutes les deux c'était à 12 années
[Musique]
vva
sous ses yeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et joue encore un délicat quand on voit
le chômage va t-elle
[Applaudissements]
c'est émouvant
non mais ça me ramène à beaucoup de
souvenirs aussi de cette période et
plein de choses voilà ça reste un
souvenir incroyable rencontre que j'ai
pu faire c'est une des plus belles
rencontres que tu as fait